sometimes the greatest stories right
these sounds look the US has been
chasing a street fighter force last week
by two five championship for quite some
time but you know who else has been
chasing that this one man right here
we're actually at a point right now
where the American could be the favorite
here more evil top aides probably than
any other player in the history of Divo
there are so many powerful names that
didn't make it this far that this is the
one player he probably did not want to
make it back out of losers bracket this
is it this is the biggest match of his
life the onus is on hunt to really close
this out this is where the mental
fortitude comes into play it's all
slipping away from him
[Applause]
heading into Evo 2017 Hajime takedo
taniguchi a fighting game legend was
entering year 10 of an Evo first place
direct he had 21 top eight finishes
including two titles in Capcom vs. SNK 2
and Super Street Fighter 2 turbo but
Evo's headlining Street Fighter Crown
had always managed to escape his grasp
Takeda was a dominant innovative master
of fighting games with dozens of
tournament wins across multiple titles
this was most visibly on display at CEO
2011 when he made history by placing
first in Street Fighter 4 Marvel vs.
Capcom 3 and blaze blue and placed third
in Tekken 6
however despite his tremendous
achievements to second place finishes in
2007 and 2013 where the closest he ever
came to claiming the most prestigious
title and fighting games the Evo Street
Fighter main event
going into Evo 2017 Street Fighter 5
tournament Tokyo had an incredibly hard
road to make it to top eight including a
showdown with a man everyone had pegged
as the favorite to win it all Viktor
Punk would a young rising superstar from
the United States with an incredible
tournament record punk had won or placed
second at nearly every major tournament
leading up to Evo he was a wunderkind
with a hyper aggressive play style a
goofy over-the-top personality it's just
another day and an uncanny ability to
get in his opponents heads
we've seen this one before although
samurai now oh my god
Punky's prize the best family I'll be
very surprised if he was not in topic
everyone was sure that hunk was going to
win Evo not good would punk looked
certain to be North America's first
Street Fighter Evo champion in years and
it seemed like Tokyo was the only
personal left who could stop him
while Tokyo's 2017 had been shaky
heading into Evo stories emerged that he
had begun to regain his form only has 21
seconds now left however you've got to
make something happen he beat the odds
but he's not taking appropriate at all
Oh stories about how he's been
performing this week in the casuals some
of your number one guys have had a
really hard time against Akita so he
could be a real problem this either the
cue clash in top 30 to the winner would
go to top eight
well the loser would have to fight their
way back through the losers bracket
there's only one more chance before
heading home more than 25 min a lot
Mario's but Punk will actually close out
this round of the huge crush counter 25
not going to be
MACUL at the head he's got him there it
is the e^x command Assam cats in there
for the throw he knows that so Quito is
blocking a lot so that's why he's
shifting to the throw the v-reversal
again punk in trouble still there's so
much offense from Tokyo under that's it
he should be able to confirm into the
critical art and there it is funk is
gonna take it over tokino and advance
over up to the winter side top aides
punk moved on and taquito defeated was
relegated to losers but he'd been there
before
Tokyo is one of Japan's five fighting
game gods and at the beginning of his
journey he did it all with a look of
cold emotionless disdain earning him the
nickname murderface
however as the years wore on he wanted
to become a player that was more fun to
watch he became known for his trash talk
if he use you voting him he's oppressive
play look at this corner oh he's got the
hip he's got the stuff he's got a full
meter but since this is gonna be enough
to kill he can't kill maybe a yell and
is over the top displays of dominance
so Kido gets up and walks off and
[Applause]
but without an Evo win in a decade
his legacy seemed incomplete he had
dedicated years of his life to being the
best years of his life to the fighting
game community to being someone that
people would remember he just needed
another chance to make it all count in
the loser's bracket taquito came up
against fellow Japanese fighting game
God heightened terrifying that these two
have to fight each other to get into top
hit their match came down to the very
last round but a huge dropped combo from
haitani gave took you to the chance to
take his place and topic you know with
the pressure the red fire but he paid
enough to kill taquitos and pop bait of
Evo and haitani
gonna be sent home after all of that
it's such a doable path and Tokyo so
elated very rare you see that out of him
but you can see how much it means to him
the next day taquito played a Filipino
champ the best dhalsim in the world
Filipino champ right here probably one
of the greatest heals that we have in
the community if you either love the guy
or you're gonna hate the guy champ took
a 2-1 lead and reached match point with
a wild series of mix-up
to get this done and is gonna take game
number three and go up to two one air
fire ball very fortunate but now you can
see this very kinetic pace from Filipino
champions going crazy with these
airports big trouble now eliminating
Tokyo
but okey doke but back lot of corner
carry all that commas right so Quito
rent for it here he gets a knock down
close to stud what's the mix of he goes
for the throw but what a protec but
across it from tokino does get the stun
could be enough to kill it's gonna be it
is you don't really having the trouble
landing a target right now Filipino
Japanese kinetic style from last round
really working right
being such a difficult target to catch
oh the beat baby bear is it coming out
so he got the battery up a bit he's so
focused on the throw he's gonna get the
game off this toe Kido a massive
comeback a huge swing and he stay
a lot it all came down to a final fifth
game defense from the Filipino champ any
teleport to the other side now a lot of
work for taquito
not always gonna be able to punish that
but he doesn't
didn't make it in time the air fireball
on the train works out needs impression
that's why Filipino Chapel the bureau's
there
do not want to be under Dawson's fire
ball when it's dropping on your head
although again II read that with Jeff be
be punchy get some drawn
it'll be no chat with a lot of resources
he's gonna go into the last round
guess they'll scramble each amp running
for his life here he's in trouble
Tokyo very close the future too though
he's got a confirm we could spend it
he's
because
make the demon set up and it got of me
because of it
Tokyo is gonna take it over Filipino
champ having narrowly escaped
elimination Tokyo moved on to play
knuckle do one of America's finest and
won against us to the demon flip he's
not sure what to do
Tokyo capitalizing he gets it this could
be the end and it is
we'll do out of the tournament one
American is left now next came a
debauchee Zanghi the world's best zangi
player known for wild unpredictable play
that tended to stump even experienced
players like toki doe the two traded
games back and forth
all in boshy this timer what a lariat he
stayed patient he took the man
we
you
crazy Tokita intern on deck
a terrific street fighter for that
was dead
the opportunity for innovation here so
if you don't kind of get there
go for the regular throw because it has
so much less whip
Abbasi time
but in the final round of their fifth
game Tepito came out on top with an
unbelievable
to kill he's just got a tiny bit left it
is not safe by any stretch of the
imagination
look at the feeder for itabashi and so
forth
and a light punch into the trigger will
still come
[Music]
for every trick in the walk up throw key
dough what a run from this guy the only
men to beat him all weekend is waiting
in that Grand Finals of evolution after
blazing a trail of destruction through a
gauntlet of street fighter fives best
players Tokyo had finally earned another
shot at Punk look the US has been
chasing a street fighter 4 / Street
Fighter 5 championship for quite some
time but you know who else has been
chasing that
this one man right here punk made it
through the winner's bracket having 302
both Edison and Casanova he was poised
to win it all and bring down Tokyo yet
again in the process with the home crowd
behind him the rookie would defeat the
veteran writing his name in Street
Fighter history but Takeda was writing
his own story beautiful speech there
from Tokyo there he has the opportunity
to go either direction is that not gonna
be a stunning
very close he hit a button he's so
genius the card he did a talk about a
punk a grand finals of evil I've never
seen him do anything like that Tokyo now
trying to take a weapon of punks into
his own arsenal finds a hip-hop is for
sure Ted
Oh landed into it he's gonna try to be
rivers let us save himself ship becomes
a concern if he can get another like
true small head
kedo dokidoki trigger oh here he comes
Tokyo has sent up to the loser's bracket
essentially the second set wasn't much
better for Papa this useful Kido events
of his past
that's a it's looking miserable here for
home hon so much
so this is
where the mental fortitude comes into
play go as well yet he has just been
walking into those standing meeting
kicks here's the same it works
he gets up from the other side and it's
gonna be an uppercut so now the next
victim should be dead or stunned
I've never seen like this is just not
prepared
he's unsettled by Pacino if the nerves
are getting to him the snakes here at
evolution the confirm again the back row
he is marching all over of Tokyo this
game is his they'll be as amazing
positioning I'll activate the v-trigger
to keep that
it's all slipping away from him
punky lost before but never in front of
a crowd like this never in front of
thousands of people and never on street
fighters most prestigious stage but
taquito destroyed him
[Music]
is that enough he is dead Tokyo gets
another round
evolution finally he's been chasing it
for so long
taquito stood victorious and to cap it
all off he struck Akuma's signature
prating demon pose hold on the evolution
says your champion soul kiddo capito
didn't need to hit Punk with a raging
demon when he was pixels away from death
but he did it anyway
he beat punk in the flashiest way
possible getting the crowd on his side
and crushing Punk spirits but he didn't
do it for that purpose taquito did it
all for the crowd he didn't end with
trash talk he closed out Evo with a
message of love for the fighting game
community you know you came all the way
from Japan is there anybody at home or
is there anybody that you want to give a
shout out to
[Music]
that's one thing I want to say fighting
game is something so great
[Music]
Tokita worked for decades to earn that
Evo win
he played dozens of games beat hundreds
of the best players on earth all to
stand at the peak once again but that
trophy meant more than a win over pomp
it meant more than experience and craft
trumping raw skill Tokyo stood at the
top of a community of people every last
one of them out to become better I can
tell you right now everybody probably
felt the same way if there was going to
be a Japanese player it was going to
stop that run they would wanted it to be
Tokyo in the end these ports aren't
always about one team or player being
better than another those teams and
players come and go glory fades but what
keeps these games going what gets you to
play what makes these moments so special
is the community that's behind them it's
the community that shapes makes and
appreciates these perfect moments for
what they are something so great
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]